they just shot it some debris from the
down Chinese spy balloon is now being
examined by U.S military forensics teams
see the smoke coming from it as China
threatens to retaliate in a statement
China's Ministry of Foreign Affairs
criticized the U.S for an obvious
overreaction and Syria's violation of
international practice further
escalating an already tense situation
clearly this was an attempt by China to
gather information to defeat our Command
and control of our sensitive missile
defense and nuclear weapon sites
questions remain as to why the balloon
wasn't brought down within minutes of
entering U.S airspace last week it was
first detected north of the Aleutian
Islands on January 28th Republicans are
pointing the finger directly at U.S
President Joe Biden who was advised
civilians could be hurt if the balloon
was shot down over populated areas he
allowed a full week for the Chinese to
conduct spying operations over the
United States over sensitive military
installations U.S China relations are
already strained disputes over beijing's
support of Russia and its war against
Ukraine and Military threats against
Taiwan and Japan analysts say this now
proves to Americans that China is a real
threat it showed the extent of China's
spying program and what they're willing
to do to gather intelligence from the
United States the Pentagon says U.S
defense took steps to block the balloon
spying capabilities military jets shot
down the surveillance balloon off the
coast of South Carolina Saturday
afternoon after it traveled across at
least 11 states suddenly we saw
something take off from the jet knew it
was a missile and you could see the
explosion debris from the balloons
spread across 11 kilometers local
residents are being warned some of it
may flow to shore this is obviously a
federal investigation we don't want to
tamper with any evidence the evidence
may be critical although the U.S
military has already concluded the
balloon's technology didn't give the
Chinese significant intelligence beyond
what it can already obtain from
satellites but the Fallout for U.S
Chinese relations will be much more
damaging
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington